Nos piden que resolvamos para "y",
el valor absoluto de "y" más 22,
esto tiene que ser menor
o igual que 13.5
Así que lo primero que voy a hacer es lo mismo
que he hecho en todos los vídeos anteriores.
Lo primero que voy a hacer es tratar de dejar
al valor absoluto de "y"
de un lado de esta desigualdad,
y para eso lo que me estorba es este 22,
por lo tanto
voy a restar 22
de ambos lados de esta desigualdad,
-22,
- 22...
¡Muy bien!
Y primero aquí estos dos se van, entonces solamente me queda el valor absoluto de "y"
esto tiene que ser menor o igual
que 13.5 menos 22
pero, ¿cuánto es 13.5 menos 22?
13.5 menos 22 bueno,
esto es exactamente
lo mismo que tomarme menos,
menos y abro paréntesis,
y voy a poner
13.5 en negativo más 22,
ó dicho otra manera
22 menos 13.5.
Al final lo único que estoy haciendo
es multiplicándolo por menos,
y 22 menos 13.5 esto es lo mismo que
13.5 para 20 es 6.5 más 2
esto es 8.5,
esto de aquí es 8.5
pero cuando lo multiplicó por menos
me queda -8.5.
Entonces me queda
que el valor absoluto de "y"
tiene que ser menor que -8.5,
y justo en este momento
es cuando algo debe decir en tu cabeza
que está mal.
Algo empieza a funcionar
muy extraño por aquí,
porque si nosotros
tomamos el valor absoluto
de cualquier número que sea,
de cualquier número que sea
éste es mayor o igual a cero,
es decir
que no hay ningún valor absoluto
que me de en negativo.
Nosotros tomamos el valor absoluto de
"a" esto igual a "x",
"x" tiene que ser un número positivo
o dicho de otra manera
"x" tiene que ser no negativo
por que no hay
ningún valor absoluto que sea negativo,
si yo por ejemplo
me tomo el valor absoluto de -3,
este es 3 positivo,
si me tomo el valor absoluto de 3
de resultado obtendría 3,
si me  tomo el valor absoluto de 0
pues es 0,
es decir que no hay ningún número
cuyo valor absoluto sea negativo,
y si esto lo traducimos
a lo que está pasando aquí,
lo que me está diciendo esta desigualdad,
es que el valor absoluto de "y"
tiene que ser
menor o igual que -8.5
pero todos los números
que sean menores que -8.5
van a ser negativos,
entonces, lo que me está diciendo esta desigualdad
es que el valor absoluto de "y"
tiene que ser negativo,
y esto no tiene nada de sentido,
justo por lo que acabamos de ver.
Cualquier número que
nos tomemos en valor absoluto
va a ser mayor o igual que 0,
por lo tanto
si yo lo que quiero es que el valor absoluto de "y"
sea menor o igual que -8.5,
esto me lleva a una contradicción
o dicho de otra manera,
si yo lo que quiero es obtener la solución
de esta desigualdad que tengo aquí,
pues la respuesta es,
que no existe ninguna solución.